so I just think that you need to look at
your three kids you need to audit them
you need to figure out what they're
strong at and you need to make 98% of
the conversation around the things that
they're strong at instead of doing what
almost most every other parent does
which is spend 85% on the 2% they're not
spend 98% on what they are some kids
need School structure some kids aren't
going to be whiz kid entrepreneurs like
some kids path is to become a lawyer and
make 130,000 a year know your kid make
them feel great about their thing don't
make them feel bad that they're not the
star athlete or the nerdiest or can make
money just build self-esteem